well
happy april 5th america where's cat
calls it cinco de april
but do you know what day it is besides
max gale's birthday
he was wojo and barney miller emily
it's our first year anniversary our
birthday this show turned one
yes it even outlasted kamala's staff
one year old just a baby but what an
amazing baby we are the type of baby who
skipped the crawling phase hell we ran
out of the womb and we never looked back
and we're certainly better than a real
baby those things suck literally
it's a thumb not your mom's breast you
dope learn the difference baby
grow up already and they never get cuter
like an adult alcoholic only uglier and
uglier until puberty when you can't even
look at them at least until they're over
18 according to my probation officer
but what does he know he's 12. but this
show's different we just get more
adorable or in my case hotter look at
this chart
you see as the months go on i just get
more and more gorgeous
i'm like a male version of caitlyn
jenner
could this explain
why the show was so successful that i
defy aging and put other gross male talk
show hosts to shame
well let's look at this other graph
created by the national association of
facial symmetry or nafs
yes my face is more symmetrical and
therefore much more attractive it's not
even close
but there are other reasons i'm great
and we'll get to that in our upcoming
special
greg gutfeld is great hosted by brian
kilmeade with special appearances by
gallagher weyland and madam and joel
osteen
[Music]
joel and i go way back
in just a few short months we steamed
past the competition handily beating
those hyped up late night shows without
even breaking a sweat
hell i'm the leah thomas of late night
but with a better ass
we were told it would take years but it
took mere months
kimmel fallon the daily show seth what's
her face
like my pants during mardi gras i'm not
sure they're still on
we even beat colbert which wasn't hard
given how depressing
depressing his show has become
it's a little known fact the colbert
show was on in epstein's cell
[Laughter]
we also crushed our news rivals too we
forced brian williams to retire we were
so brutal cnn simply crumbled chris
cuomo jeff sucker one could say they'd
still be there if we weren't here
and that one would be jesus
christ in just one year
we've accomplished so much
but so many in the media had to hate it
at the start they trashed the show they
said we'd be underwater like a kennedy
date
until they saw the ratings then the
haters hid where did these critics go
well just follow the scent of fruitless
masturbation
that's calvin klein's latest fragrance
but at least one cable network is
covering us
tonight on the chess news network
david brooks with the chess news network
covering america's national nightmare
day 365 of the gutfeld show as you can
see these streets are thick with
protesters
oh here's one now miss miss uh you don't
know anyone who watches the gutfeld show
do you actually i do number one well
you're you're just one person no i don't
think you understand my dad watches it
with my brother and my grandma only says
he videos joe
thank you get out of here
well congratulations on your stupid show
back to you gus yes
you know a lot of people would say greg
you should take credit for this yourself
you really did it all you're amazing and
i love you
well thank you a lot of people
but it's unfair other people were here
to help put this show together like cat
where would we be without her
we'd probably be fine
she's like a toothpick skinny sharp and
easily fits into dark disgusting places
she's the girl of your dreams if you
want a blonde freddy krueger she's like
last week's christmas tree out in the
street after covering your floor with
needles he always has the last laugh
because anyone who hears it immediately
wants to die
she thought a a was byob she's like an
alarm clock will not stop making noise
until you pay attention to her everyone
at the bar yells cheers when she finally
leaves fox news contributor cat tip ah
yes
also there's tom chalu he's been here
since the beginning like adam eve and
nancy pelosi he does a better joe biden
than joe biden
come on man i don't need
any notes and you can take that to the
bank
your lion
dot facebook
take it easy
take it easy
don't let the sound of your own wheels
let's go brandon
you know when a problem comes along you
must whip it before the cream sets out
too long you must whip it when
something's going wrong you must whip it
whip it good and i am ready to go i am
ready to dance man
i love that
beautiful
and what can you say about our angry
black male
what it is gut phil
well here we are it's been a year
how are we doing and when we started
they treat us
like we stole something hated us would
never work we're not talented enough
well
they were kind of right we did steal
something we stole the number one spot
we even spotted him 25 million 25
million and we still put hands on you
and now we're running stuff so special
shout out to cat tim
tom the whole team gene
everybody who makes work both gabrielles
or gabby's whatever they're comfortable
with
it was a team effort
and we're kicking ass and taking names
so gutfield
i guess you are the luckiest leprechaun
of all time
[Music]
and no surprise fox has been grateful
our ratings translate into dollars and
we're making the top brass very rich as
we become addicted to pills
[Laughter]
here are some workplace well-wishers you
can feel the love
[Music]
dana are you excited about the one year
anniversary of the gutfeld show
it's only been one year it's like dog
years it feels like seven
hey jesse it's the one year anniversary
of gutfeld anything you want to say i'm
sorry i gotta get to a meeting
susan lee anything to say for greg's
anniversary yeah he owes me money
gray
who's craig
yeah what's up bill himmer anything to
say about the one year anniversary
who's this for greg gutfeld got filmed
i'll pass
well anyway the show became the talk of
the industry like my random explosive
diarrhea people either loved it or hated
it but they couldn't stop talking about
it
there is a new king of late night and
his name is greg gutfeld fox news found
a good thing they they can make fun of
liberals and they are doing it to great
success
so true but even better when he had
quentin tarantino
on and they both got high and then they
tried to analyze this show i've heard
you talk about on your show the gut
filled show but talk to me more in
detail what do you think about
him per se i i mean we did a bit on that
i
don't remember talking about it because
honestly i don't know it oh have you
watched a couple episodes of the show no
but what no you haven't watched
not even two not two seconds
not two seconds no
i that's why we didn't do a bid on i i i
issue on it wreck gutfield is working
now
there's something to work from but the
left is goofy
in a lot of ways so there is material
now
for someone like gretch gutfield to work
with
maybe he's doing it and i'm missing it
but i'm going by what they say in my
writer producer meeting it does have a
feeling of the which i'll call it uh the
wally george show
all right
that's but that's actually insincere
because there is a
we're not going to talk about his show
for that much on the show
oh i don't care no but i don't i'm like
i'm much more concerned that we're out
of pot
oh that was amazing i wish tarantino had
completed his thought but it's kind of
nice to see them chatting about this
show it means we punctured their bubble
and we're not done we should also thank
our producers who make me look better
than i really am if that's indeed
possible but the biggest thanks go to
you dear viewer you checked us out and
like a serial killer dismembering a
victim
you liked what you saw
you stuck by us you spread the word and
now we're the most successful late night
show in the history of all television
that's probably not true but are you
gonna fact check it really yeah right
after you clean behind your refrigerator
but that's the beauty of tv and the
beauty of me thank you america on to
another year of us
let's welcome tonight's guest he's so
white he has to wear sunscreen to the
planetarium fox news contributor tom
chalu
she talks so fast she makes me feel like
i should be placing a bid on a cow
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
if his audience member busts a gut it's
because they have appendicitis actor
writer and comedian jamie lisao
and april showers is her reminder to
bathe this month fox news contributor
cat tim
now i believe because this is such a
special evening uh we should have some
cake do we have cake some oh look who's
here
all right
gene brought us some cake um it's so
nice of you to get dressed up
you're also a bike messenger apparently
um
can you slice it up for us
and
then get it to all the guests and um
don't take your time or anything
my goodness
you think you take more you know
emily
how are you i'm so excited for you you
guys happy birthday honestly this is
awesome this was this is awesome i'm
really thrilled for you it's it is kind
of amazing how many people i could fit
on my coattails especially you
you're welcome that i'm sitting next to
you no i'm genuinely so excited for you
and so thrilled i think this is an
amazing accomplishment really and i know
i i definitely represent millions of
people and that support and that love
and just seeing you shine i think that
i'm truly thrilled to be here tonight to
support you in the anniversary everybody
i mean i speak for the whole team um in
terms of my respect and admiration and
just not so fast
i don't i don't know if you speak for me
but i show support and gratitude for the
whole team oh there you go jamie i mean
you must be incredibly grateful because
i'm able to get fly you out of alaska to
come here and change your sad and lonely
life
it's really amazing i just wanted to
point out that cake thing was less
organized than bill maher and quentin
tarantino
it was which i didn't think was possible
you know we rehearsed it someone should
tell those guys that they're recording
i don't think they knew that was amazing
okay let me ask you this yeah
what did you think
quentin tarantino was about to say
that's what i'm i'm i'm like trying to
find it's obvious he's watching it he's
watching it and it's like you couldn't
say if he was gonna he mentions wally
george which was a kind of a satirical
pro thank you uh satirical perform
that's a parodic parodied he pretended
to be somebody maybe that's what he
thought i was or he's but or in that it
was insincere but i got the feeling that
he liked it i think so and i think you
would know because i think you have like
the most context do you believe that
bill maher only watched two seconds no
that was that was baloney but then again
he might not watch anything that's true
if i were bill maher i wouldn't watch
anything i'd go i'm almost going to die
soon that's true i think it's amazing
that quentin tarantino watches the show
i don't have to say that i think that's
amazing everybody watches so i'm just
saying i was halfway through that video
uh the bill maher thing and i thought it
was like you and gene doing silly voices
on a video really yeah i i was like in
your face you were looking you look
completely confused i was like i thought
this is a hilarious parody and i was
like wait a minute this is those guys
actually getting stoned and talking
about greg it's hilarious yeah i thought
tom was playing the microphone
so um kat
take the stage talk about this you have
been you've been on this show since the
start
yes i have this is more exciting than
probably my my birthday and that's not
just because
so much bad stuff happened on my
birthday
um but yeah it's obviously like i wanted
to be on red eye like way before you
knew i existed that was my goal that i
wanted to be on red eye and so now for
this to happen
it's really amazing and i'm really busy
so i've like never
drank less but i've never been accused
of being drunk more
that's true you do put up with a lot of
my crap yes people don't understand
though at home
that she writes half of the interview
yeah
she's writing the ones that you go
please let some woman where are you at
that bar we were at that bar oh yeah
yeah started yelling at us and he was
like stop being so mean to cat i was
like i'm right here i'm right here and
we're hanging out we're friends we're
friends
and i go look i go
she writes them yeah she writes the
insults and she goes i don't care
and she said she was a big fan and she
was upset so people write but they don't
understand this is what we do this is
what all of us if you can't tease
somebody then you don't like them
right i also think that's why tarantino
and a lot of hollywood people i don't
know if they get it greg because in
hollywood everything is about production
and budgets and they they make
everything very slick but there's
nothing behind it obviously there's not
a huge budget for this show
but what's behind it
what i'm saying
on the show this is what i'm saying greg
obviously yeah i think he watches it and
he says wait a minute how is the show
getting such high ratings when in fact
it's just a bunch of people having fun
and it does have the feel of something
thrown together when i used to watch red
eye i was like am i the only one who
loves this show like i didn't i couldn't
believe that other people loved it as
much as i did and then when i saw the
ratings i was like oh i'm not alone yeah
that would the thing is
a famous person once said about this
show
that we don't let professionalism get in
the way of the product that's perfect i
don't have any of that yeah but i mean
it's true it's like it was like a
throwaway comment
and it's like for people for people
who'd noticed we don't even have the
music anymore we took it away because of
the war and it's like it's something
that is endemic to
a professional show but it doesn't feel
like we need it right it feels like you
could just have a conversation you don't
need to have music there's a lot of
things you don't really need in a show
to make it great
and and to that point a lot of shows
that are
are seen as great are only just simply
professional
right yeah it's all slick there's
nothing wrong with it and anderson
cooper there's nothing interesting about
him but there's something professional
about him everything about him just
oozes professionalism and you can almost
say that about it like even seth meyers
his show looks nice but there's nothing
there you don't have rules to follow
that's a that's a good thing right i
play but you know what
i play by my own rules
i'm america's bad boy don't get in my
way i'll crush you i'll crush you like a
bug
all right including actual bugs of
course you too bugs you bugs if you're
on another person i'll crush the person
and the bug
all right
up next a city that drove people away
now begs them to return if they're gay
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else